is the head coach of Michigan State
basketball one of our favorite guests
right here on the show he is none other
than Tom Izzo going to the Final Four as
the Big Ten champs beat Duke to take on
Texas Tech on Saturday right here on the
Rich Eisen show how are you coach
I'm good rich how are you I'm hanging in
there
I'm hanging in there congratulations on
getting to the Final Four right how are
you uh how does that voice holding up of
yours right now is good you know just
whenever I told you whenever I lack a
little sleep my voice goes and you know
I'm bringing in our boy mooch he's
coming in for the weekend so that'll be
fun to have him there and but it was a
heck of a run for rich and as you know
we kind of been his different team and
I've had lately but but when you get a
good quarterback a lot of things can
happen and I've got one of the better
quarterbacks and kind of got a team
that's kind of stayed connected and all
of a sudden I mean III could say I
predicted this it's been a little
shocking but we really played good the
last ten twelve games fourteen games of
the season and kind of got better each
game why are you shocked what we threw
that it's not as an imposing of a lineup
as you maybe would seen even in the last
six eight years you know and we've had
some teams that had you know we never
have a Duke or Kentucky team but we've
had some teams that have some great
talent on it and this team has very good
talent but it's that the hole is better
than the parts and there's been some
teams the parts is better than all so I
guess at the end of the day I think you
like the hole to be better than the
parts and that's what we have well what
was what what was the difference-maker
do you think in beating Duke
you know I think experience you know I
really do I think you know the only kid
read issue was out the game before and
then he came back and I've learned with
injuries man when when every year go out
it's harder to come back and I just
thought the experience maybe that we had
with a couple players and their youth
their very talent and they got a great
team and mike is a hell of a coach and
he's he's got you can argue it but it's
been the best program maybe ever I mean
UCLA was UCLA but this day and age had
so many good teams
I think the consistency they played with
has been special in Zion his I really
had a great appreciation for him glad he
was in college even if it was only a
year but he he plays a lot of energy and
heart and toughness and so I think for
us it was just the experience you know
we didn't shoot it great within
rebounded off the charts what we did is
we didn't turn the ball over and they
did turn the ball over and you're a big
football guy you know whenever there is
a Super Bowl who usually wins it or
never seen turns it over the least it's
not much different in our support yeah I
know I mean in terms of in terms of you
know experience there it was a quick
shot of Xavier giving Cassius Winston a
little sort of nod right I mean Xavier
Tillman given giving him sort of like a
look sort of an eyebrow raised and moved
his moved his face in the direction of
Winston to run up the floor to run out
the clock with five seconds to go is
that coached you coach him those facial
expressions I mean we had but that one
didn't work and I it was I didn't see it
till later right and he didn't even say
anything but the way Xavier did it and
then I got mad at Casas in the in the
locker room because I said where you
been hiding because that burst of speed
when he went even Brys I on I said where
you've been hiding for the last three
years you know I never seen you run like
that but then again I buy a giant you
know chasing me I probably run like that
in my
so I guess it all worked out and it was
a connection and that's a great example
of the connection that these players
have for each other
that was Savior in Cash's connection I
know and so Zion has eyeball enemies as
advertised Oh coach he's really good
really good yeah I know and obviously
though your team is the one moving on
coach Tom Izzo here on the Rich Eisen
show you mentioned about you know having
fun with Cassius Winston in the locker
room and you know you got on him I mean
the fact that you were right in the
middle of a cross hairs in the middle of
this tournament of a conversation about
coaching a player too hard I mean now
that you're a week removed two weeks
removed from all that what was that like
for you to be in the middle of that
conversation it was interesting it was a
five-second deal on a kid that I've
known and recruited for twenty or two
years and it was a I was amazed how much
it got but then again you know I'm
ever-evolving too you know as you are in
your job and and I just got to realize
it's a different time different dates so
I'll I'll say this I will never not hold
the guy accountable and never does
anything happen that happened once or
twice or three times in other words if a
guy is a class you know we don't we
don't kill them we don't run them in the
morning we don't do it now if he misses
six or seven of them it changes as it
would with your own kids and so there
were some things that happened earlier
and that nobody's aware of and but I
guess you know different day and age so
I'll just find a different way to get
about but holding kids accountable or
holding people accountable I still think
is what our country lacks and I'm going
to be lacked here I just got to find a
way to do it that is maybe doesn't hurt
somebody's feelings it didn't hurt his
feelings
it didn't hurt his family's feelings but
I guess it hurt other people's feelings
well I mean it is a video that you've
watched back no no no come on No
did did something wrong in the school
what would you do hey Tom you know I was
I was I was I was in Italy while this
all happened we're on vacation with my
with my kids and and my wife and I came
back and I sat down and I I said into a
microphone I got people calling in after
I said that you were just coaching a kid
that you knew and somebody somebody
called in and said to me what if he did
that to your son and I'm like if you if
you need to be held accountable in that
manner where the god that I know he had
his best interest in mind that he was
gonna call him for the rest of his life
and have him on his team for the rest of
his life I'm cool it and I'm not just
saying that cuz you're calling and I've
got to make adjustments to rich I mean I
mean it is a different time but that the
key phrase you just said what is the
relationship like you know does the
player know the coach does the coach
know the player and like I said if I had
Aaron call you today it would have been
zero if I had him if I had his dad call
you today his dad gave me the liners I
didn't send him there to be pampered I
sent him there to be pushed I know what
it's like where he wants to get I know
how hard it is and and so you know
little overreaction as Jud Heathcote
used to say the game makes fools of us
all so if I had a moment when I could
have just had said it a little
differently or maybe without pointing
but I think one of the things I've
always been is pretty transparent so if
somebody's doing that into practice and
not in the game does that make it better
you know just happens that mine was out
in a game and so I will apologize to
anybody I offended and I will adjust and
learn but the accountability part will
never change as long as I'm here I'll
tell you you know I know you're probably
not on Twitter but Mark Cuban talked
about it on Twitter saying that the
thing that he found most interesting
about it was the way the other players
were reacting to the situation and how
they kind of put hands on you and you
didn't react to it at all like it was
just like a normal family argument is
what it looked like you know I don't
know if we watched it back in that
manner
you know dream on I mean dream on is
very Mon you know and but it really is
so different than people have made it
they act like every day there's
something going on and you know me and
you know my buddy Mariucci girl and he's
with us a lot during this time and I
tell you what rich if anybody's got
better relationships with their players
or if anybody keeps better relationships
once they're gone I challenge anybody I
mean I think that's one of the strengths
we have it's not that anything else and
trust me it was blown out of proportion
but I learned from it too and and I
guess that's the key I'll learn from it
and find different ways to do things but
the bottom line of things is people
still need to be held accountable in a
30-second timeout you don't have as much
time to negotiate hey listen this is
what you got to do this is what you
gotta do
Tom Izzo here a few more minutes left
for the Michigan State head coach did I
hear you and your press conference say
that you needed a second championship to
validate your run there at Michigan
State he's in a couple times the
question in the press conference was I'm
glad you're gonna help me straighten it
out okay that somebody said there are
people out there saying you need to win
another one what do you say to those
people and I said I agree with them you
know because I want to win one every
year you know and that is the goal I
mean realistic or unrealistic I mean and
I shouldn't say that every year because
some years it's not realistic and if I'd
tried that I'd be phony so but that is
the goal and that is the goal this year
and I don't think I should be judged on
that but then again I I I'm I got my big
boy pants on I I think people can
evaluate if I win another one I'm still
three behind Mike and I'm I'm seven
behind eight behind John Wooden so you
know there's always going to be another
of another of another and and that's
what keeps me rolling I'm I'm good with
that so I don't think I think you need
to be validated on how your team
gets better and and how your team is the
championship sometimes our are lucky I
mean hey let me tell you Duke is a very
very good team championship caliber team
in a one in done moment we got the best
of them for that day I'd hate to see if
it was a best out of seven series I'm
not sure I'd better myself the same way
so as you head off to Minneapolis coach
you'll hear a lot of story lines about
you potentially beating Texas Tech and
make make it to the final game can I
give you one that you probably haven't
heard yet and you won't hear well you
get to Minneapolis well okay we go
avenging Michigan's loss the Texas Tech
on behalf of all the Wolverines go ahead
and do it you know because Michigan lost
to them yeah I know deep down you'd like
to do that on behalf of the Wolverines I
know that Tom a look would I would
because I do have you know I have great
respect for John and their team and you
know everybody talks about us getting
them three times this year well last
time they got us twice last year and you
know I think everybody would agree we
were the better team at least record
wise now they went on to a Final Four
but I'm just saying you know I bet on
both sides of the coin and so I never I
never get too excited about it I
definitely never talked about it that
anytime you beat your rival any time
it's a good day but it's only one day
fantastic well enjoy the time somebody
asked me the other day I forget who is
much gonna be there for Izzo and I'm
like are you kidding me he's gonna he's
gonna be sitting on Magic Johnson's lap
like a ventriloquist dummy are you
kidding me he's gonna be sitting right
there our magic lap of course he's going
to be there
I know I know so he's free to come he's
freed up he's free you wouldn't miss
that I know for the world
coach Congrats on the Final Four
Congrats on the Final Four and you know
again do it for Michigan Tom do it for
Michigan kind to me I'm gonna try to do
it for the conference and for the state
and for the University of Michigan yes
because of Texas there you go that's it
it's on tape it's recorded forevermore
Tom thanks again soon thank you go
that's Tom Izzo Michigan State head
coach the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience